what if a writer believes that Hollywood
has not created anything new in the last
20 years anything
original and that a lot
of I mean awful is is a strong word but
they have sort of a bitterness towards
the writing and they feel like Hollywood
won't give them a
chance they're not going to get a chance
with that
attitude um if you feel like nothing
good has been written in 20
years who wants to talk to
you who who and you feel that your thing
is the best thing that's been written in
20 years you're probably delusional and
people will run in the other
direction what if someone wants to write
something a little more conservative and
they feel that their values don't line
up find a place where your values will
line up find the outlet where your
values will line up look at what
that
company has produced and go towards the
place where they're making content that
feels like it shares your
values what mindset or attitude should a
writer
have
optimistic excited without being
annoying um interested interested in the
other person um feeling like they're are
some great things out there it it speaks
to what you said before what if you
think nothing good has been
written they think there's some great
content and they say that's the kind of
content I want to make so the attitude
is one of possibility of optimism of
being upbeat again without being
annoying of being interested of being
passionate okay we're friendly but we're
not poana friendly
without being your best friend do you
know what I mean don't do that don't
don't assume that this person wants to
be friends with best friends with you
yeah that's interesting look like a date
it's like a date how does someone show
they're a leader without speaking
it by how you carry yourself by your
confidence again confidence not
not bragger not
obnoxiousness um somebody who has quiet
confidence somebody who's
decisive you know would you like water
or a Diet Coke I'll have the water
please even just that if you go
um I no that no that's not
leadership you had talked about
something in in some of your either
course notes or something that you know
showing an attitude that the person's a
team player well how do we see that
because if I say I'm a team player you
can't
Sayer okay
[Music]
um it's by having a sense of selfworth
that's what you have to come in with
have boundaries be friendly but not
again a puppy dog um and if you're
interested in somebody else with not to
the detriment of you but if you have the
confidence to be interested in somebody
and ask about them and also talk about
yourself which is a fine line and
sometimes hard
um somebody may see you interact with
somebody else you're going to order a
coffee or a drink and you're a b word or
a s word or any other kind of word and
and they here's another thing speaking
about that how you treat assistance says
so much about you if you I when I was
hiring somebody when I was at amling
this person came in he was mean to my
assistant he never even had a chance he
was really qualified but he didn't have
a chance so it's how you treat other
people again without being Snivy and and
and sort of rolling over and saying
please please please but I have
something to offer and I think you'll
like it you may not that's okay too um
in the in the most positive kind of a
way how does someone show they're a team
player oh how do you show your a team
player by listening to other team
players are people that listen to other
people and they add something to what
that person said that elevates what that
person said they chip in they're willing
to be part of a group and their their
mindset is how can I help this group how
can I add to this how can I be additive
you know we hear you have to know the
right people in the entertainment
industry how do you identify who the
right people
are the right people are people who
respond to who you are they're people
that have some Authority they're people
who can make things happen there's
people who have relationships with other
people they may be decision makers those
are the right people they're people who
know decision makers in a positive way
they're people who want to lift you up
that's the right
people once you identify the right
person or people how do you meet them
the girl great news is there's social
media you can go to events I mean now
that the pandemic is sort of kind of in
the rearview mirror there are Live
Events Again The Writers Guild of
America Foundation I I mean we're in the
middle of a strike right now so nothing
is going to happen then but when the
strike is over they have live inperson
panels and you can go think about
meeting peers people at your level
rather than I've got to go rush and talk
to the speaker meet people at your level
they'll come up with you at the same
time um events social media you can if
if there's somebody who you would like
to meet and they're on social media you
can like what they post you can repost
it or retweet it you can make a comment
about it like I really love
the episode about the freight train and
then you say you know I grew up on a
freight train it really was authentic
you can do that and if you do that
enough they'll get to know who you are
and you might DM them and say I'm such a
huge fan of yours and I'm an aspiring
writer if you ever had 15 minutes for a
zoom coffee I'd love to hear about your
journey and maybe get some advice now
you can't do that with somebody that's
up here do that with lower and midlevel
people you don't need to meet the
president of the studio you just need to
meet some people who are in farther than
you are and again it takes time it's not
yes it's it's not follow someone and
then hey ask them hey I'm a writer will
you read my script we talked about that
don't ask people to read your script
until you have a true Rel relationship
with them I know you don't like the word
networking you said connecting mhm okay
that's that's a great alternative what
else should a new writer know about
connecting you should have your story so
that when somebody says what do you do
you can answer that in a interesting way
you should know who you're going to be
meeting with if you possibly can and do
some research about them so you you
should be open and
friendly and be interested in the other
person again not step all over yourself
but it should be 70% about them and 30%
about you ask about them now there's
somebody who will start talking and
never stop talking about themselves go
say excuse me I have to get a drink and
leave but for most people be interested
in other people that goes think about
the people you know who are friendly and
have a lot of friends they are
interested in other
people that's what you want to do when
you're connecting and you want to look
for genuine connection and if it's not
there that's okay go on to the next
person